Speaker 1: Donald Trump has been humiliated
after teasing a major announcement.
And the major announcement is Trump digital
trading cards, including one where Trump is
dressed like an astronaut.
I. I don't know how else to explain it.
All day Wednesday, it was being teased that
on Thursday Trump was going to make a huge
announcement and speculation was, is he dropping
out of the race?
Is he announcing who is vice president is
going to be?
No.
The announcement posted to Trump's truth social.
Speaker 2: Circle.
Speaker 1: Was as follows Major announcement.
My official Donald Trump digital trading card
collection is here.
These limited edition cards feature amazing
art of my life and career.
Collect all of your favorite Trump digital
trading cards.
Very much like a baseball card.
But hopefully much more exciting.
Go to collect trump card XCOM and get your
cards now.
Only $99 each would make a great Christmas
gift.
Don't wait.
They all will be gone, I believe very quickly.
This is a complete and total humiliation.
A former president of the United States running
again teases a major announcement.
And the announcement is digital trading cards,
one in which Trump is dressed like Superman.
One in which he's dressed like an astronaut.
And a bunch of others that are just completely
bizarre and pathetic.
Trump's major announcement teases for release
of digital card collection, writes Brett Samuels
for The Hill.
While some speculated the announcement would
be related to the speaker race playing out
among House Republicans or Trump's largely
inactive 2024 presidential campaign, it was
instead about a new moneymaking outlet for
the former president.
Trump boasted about the cards.
Sales are not affiliated with the campaign.
The reveal elicited mockery from liberals
and disbelief from conservatives.
Folks, look at this website we are on collect
trump card wsj.com.
There is a sweepstakes.
Each digital trading card NFT is not only
a rare collectible that automatically enters
you into a sweepstakes for a chance to win
thousands of incredible prizes and meet the
one and only number 45.
The cards are only $99 each, and you need
a wallet.
Folks.
What the hell is going on?
It's almost 20, 23.
I don't think I would have guessed that Trump
would be running for office.
But not campaigning.
Not leaving his house.
But making sweaty speeches that require a
hundred takes to get right while promoting
digital trading cards.
I didn't have that on my bingo card, I will
admit, but it's going to be a whacky year.
I hope all of you will be with us.
Make sure you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel and folks.
Friday, December 23rd.
Okay.
Year end membership special.
Huge discount.
Your first month's payment will be donated
to charity.
Okay, this is.
We've never done something like this before,
and it's going to be absolutely fantastic.
Okay.
You get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot
com.
Friday the 23rd, you'll get an email saying,
here's how you get a membership with a large
discount.
You become a member.
You get all the membership benefits, including
the bonus show.
Speaker 3: The bonus show where you want to
make money.
Speaker 2: Yeah, everybody else.
It makes money to fund themselves.
Speaker 1: You get all of that.
We take your first month's payment and donate
it to charity.
I will be saying more about the charity next
week, but basically we're sending people cash
to a charity that sends people cash, which
I believe is the best way to actually help
people get on the newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
More info next week.
The David Pakman Show is, of course a community
funded program.
We depend on the bonus show and actually the
membership program in general to support the
work that we do.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code 24 starts now.
And as a reminder, Friday, December 23rd,
we will be doing our end of the year membership
special wherein you will get a discount off
of your membership.
If you use a certain code, your first month's
payment will be donated back through give
directly and it will be doubled.
It will be double, double your impact.
We've never done something like this before
and I'm super excited.
Just get on my mailing list at David Pakman
dot com and then you'll get all the info on
Friday, December 23rd.